well nathan gunner congratulations guys
you're moving forward in the third and
final round of competition you made your
first blades out of guillotines and
we're going to continue on with the
darker side of history theme by asking
you to build this blade
four days
the executioner sword
[Music]
the executioner sword performed its
bloody work in 16th century central
europe unlike combat swords this lethal
blade features a straight double-edged
cutting blade with a blunt tip perfect
for swiftly chopping off the heads of
criminals this deadly weapon was used on
many aristocratic felons rather than the
axe since it allowed the victim to meet
his end in a dignified kneeling position
rather than laying face down with his
head on the block while the
executioner's sword fell out of use in
the early 18th century this gruesome
sword is still wielded in the 2019 video
game mordhau the boys good luck we will
see you in four days
my name is nathan anderson from west
valley utah i'm a maintenance worker at
the utah's hogel zoo i loved animals and
there's not too many places where i can
be welding and look up and see a giraffe
right there if i win forged in fire the
ten thousand dollars is gonna go to
taking my wife on a trip to go looking
for bigfoot heat treat coming up just
don't wanna rush it i don't wanna break
it cause that would be
bad all right
i don't think that anything went wrong i
feel pretty good about the quench should
be able to clean everything up move on
forward from here so now it's time to
start working on the guard i've got my
finials right there
hopefully those won't add too much
weight for what i want to go for but i
think i'm sitting pretty good for right
now there we go i've got the guard
fitting where i want it to i need the
handle comfortable so that there's not a
reason to be sent home as good as it's
gonna get and then we'll pin it
so i start engraving skulls and some
flames and things like that to kind of
make it my own
pretty close
give it a test
this blade is so good i can smell
bigfoot now
[Music]
my name is gunnar wilbanks i'm a high
school football coach and teacher and
i'm part-time bladesmith my wife loves
it every time i make a knife i bring it
in to her both of my daughters and my
son they all have to hold it and it
turns out we all love blades
a few hours in and i'm almost halfway
there kind of forgot what it was like in
the little man's world just working with
a hammer because i don't have the power
tools i'm having trouble getting it
heated evenly because my forge is short
every time i slide my blade through it's
so long it wants to droop on one end
well every time that i'm getting down
here and getting the back end of it hot
the front end of it's cooling off
we gotta get the timing right right here
i get it in the quench tank
i don't feel any tings i don't feel any
cracks anything like that
that's not the sound you want to hear
it's soft on both ends that's not gonna
work
plan b is to go in for a second quench
and instead of laying the blade flat
i'll lay it upright maybe i'll be able
to hold the heat a little bit better
that way and the blade's not gonna sag
on me if the quench doesn't go well i go
all the way back and start at ground
zero
you jesus
thank you
i'm elated that i'm actually going to be
able to use this blade
it seems to be going great
all right so far so good and hopefully
god willing and the creek don't rise
they might say you're the forging fire
champion
it will kill
basements welcome
to the keel test
the executioner sword that word alone
just gives you visions of decapitated
heads
so to find out what kind of lethal
damage your executioner's sword can do
i'll deliver some more lethal blows on
this ballistic stummy
nathan is it time it's time have fun
[Music]
holy crap
just a little off the top
[Laughter]
all right nathan
first up this is a heavy beast it is so
forward heavy that you need two hands to
control that now your handle
construction is smooth i'll give you
that but it also feels a little bit
rounded over here where it actually
gives me much more control sideways than
it does this way but overall your
weapons sir
you'll kill awesome
all right gunner your turns are you
ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
all right gunners talk about your
executioner sword over here
your blade right here has a finer grind
so it makes it a little bit lighter and
the edge that you have here when it came
to that skull just glided into that
overall sir your executioner's sword it
will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the skull and bone chop
now to test the overall construction of
your blades as well as how they feel
while they're being used i'll be
chopping into these skulls and that
nasty giraffe bone
nathan you're up you ready yes sir have
fun
[Music]
uh
holy giraffe
all right nathan so right off man this
thing is heavy once you get it moving
it's going but controlling it's tough
having said that your edge held up
beautifully it's still just as sharp as
when i started which is pretty darn
sharp so good job on that thanks i like
sharp things
gunner ready
what if i said no
i'd say
you don't watch the show much do you
exactly
[Music]
[Music]
all right so gonna right off lighter
blade easier to control a lot of that
has to do with effect you've got more
handle here
now your blade it's got some compacting
on the edges but i wouldn't run my
finger down this edge it's still plenty
sharp nicely done thank you sir
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the jackfruit and water
jug slice
ethan you're up first you ready yes sir
have fun all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
still sharp
all right nathan
as far as the downward chop
it's a very clean cut
easy no resistance whatsoever now when i
was cutting as soon as i met the
resistance of the water it kind of
rolled on my hand
but anything that it did have contact
with it was able to cut overall sir your
weapon
it will cut thank you
all right go under your returns are you
ready yes sir i am let's do this
[Music]
all right gunner the handle construction
you have here is wide and ovoid enough
to where when i hold on to it i can
really tell where the edge is and it's
much easier to control a blade like this
in the slice you can see that cuts
nicely overall sir your weapon
do a cut
thank you
well bladesmiths only one of you can
leave here with the title of fortune
fire champion and get that check for ten
thousand dollars now the judges
discussed your blades and they made a
final decision
today's force and fire champion is
gunner congratulations now nathan you
fought hard man but unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut i'm gonna have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you very much
congratulations thanks
well i'm gonna have to find a different
way to take my wife to go see bigfoot
but we're still gonna go
well gunner that makes you the fortune
fire champion you just got yourself a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you appreciate it
guys
[Applause]
i just won forged in fire
feeling good
i mean i never thought i would
make it this far from day one
i don't necessarily think that i'm a
better smith than any of these other
guys it just worked out in my favor
today
as far as the money uh after football
season ends my wife and i'll probably
take a long weekend somewhere
you